SCOTT LOH: The
Associate Fire Program
allows us to leave our roles
as University employees
and answer calls for help within
the municipality of Princeton.
[SIREN]
The municipality has a 100%
volunteer fire department.
During the day,
that's a challenge
as far as a manpower standpoint.
So the fact that the University
has employees right here that
can respond and are
willing to respond
is a tremendous help and asset
to the town where manpower
would normally not be
found because volunteers
are typically out working
their job from nine to five.
SANDRA KEARNEY: So when the
University started the program,
I heard about it and decided
that since I'm already
a volunteer firefighter, it
would be a great opportunity
to not only service
the town that I live in
but also service the
town that I work in.
The training?
We do two trainings a month.
And we also do some live
burns a couple times a year
where we actually go out
and do practical training
with the fire and go
to the Fire Academy.
DAN TOMALIN: The associate program with the,
University, they're the same as we are.
They're part, they're actually
members of the Fire Department.
So they go.
If they get there
first, they start
doing whatever needs to be done.
And they do everything.
Firefighting.
Rescue.
They help with car accidents.
Everything that we do, they do.
And it's a huge help.
LIZ LEMPERT: When it comes to
public safety and fire safety,
the goals of the University
and the community
are completely in line.
And this is an area where
it's ripe for collaboration.
And I'm proud that this
has been an area where
the University and the town
have been working together
both in terms of putting
together a volunteer force
and the University helping
with some of the major expenses
to make sure that we
have the equipment we
need to outfit our volunteers.
The town has purchased
two new fire trucks for us
to use, totaling $1.4 million.
The University is helping
with that purchase
with a contribution of $500,000.
MICHAEL KERVAN: Anyone who is
an employee of the University
is allowed to join the program.
We provide the training and
the time for you to respond.
And right now, I believe
we have around 30 members.
And we're looking to
have around a pool of 50
that we can use for
our duty schedule.
SANDRA KEARNEY:
There's a lot of things
that I love about
being a firefighter.
The camaraderie, the feeling
of being a part of something.
You know?
And helping people.
We do activities
outside of training.
And then we all train together.
STEVE ELWOOD: The best
part about the program
and why I enjoy it so much
is because it's given me
an opportunity to meet many
folks at the University
and throughout the
community that I otherwise
wouldn't have met.
And also it gives
me an opportunity
to give back to the
local community.
SIREN